la relación entre el cambio de energía
libre y q el cociente de reacción es muy
importante el cambio de energía libre o
delta g es la diferencia instantánea de
la energía libre entre los reactivos y
los productos mientras que q es el
cociente de reacción y nos ayuda a saber
en donde nos encontramos en la reacción
tiene la misma forma de la constante de
equilibrio k por otro lado delta g 0 es
el cambio de energía libre estándar es
decir es el cambio libre de energía pero
en condiciones estándar r es la
constante de los gases y t es la
temperatura en grados kelvin ahora
cuando delta g es menor que cero es
decir cuando es negativa la reacción es
espontánea pero si delta g es mayor a
cero es decir si es positiva la reacción
es no espontánea y cuando delta g es
igual a cero
la reacción se encuentra en equilibrio
veamos algunos ejemplos esta es una
reacción para sintetizar amoniaco y
nuestro objetivo es calcular el cambio
de energía para la siguiente reacción a
25 grados celsius dado el siguiente
conjunto de presiones parciales entonces
nitrógeno gaseoso más hidrógeno gaseoso
nos da amoniaco gaseoso y a 25 grados
celsius el cambio de energía estándar
delta g 0 es igual a menos 33.0 kilo
jules recuerde para los gases es más
fácil medir la presión que la
concentración por eso en este instante
específico de la reacción las presiones
parciales para todos estos gases es de
una atmósfera una atmósfera para el
nitrógeno una atmósfera para el
hidrógeno y una atmósfera para el
amoniaco entonces calculemos la energía
libre del traje vamos a escribir nuestra
reacción
delta g es igual a delta g 0 + rt por el
logaritmo natural de q ok
primero necesitamos calcular q el
cociente de reacción recuerde tiene la
misma forma que la constante de
equilibrio anteriormente vimos que la
constante de equilibrio es igual a la
concentración de los productos entre la
concentración de los reactivos y cada
concentración es elevada a la misma
potencia que tengamos como coeficiente
pero aquí en lugar de concentraciones
estamos usando presiones parciales
entonces podemos escribir q subíndice p
para indicar que estamos trabajando con
las presiones parciales entonces nos
queda q es igual a la presión parcial de
amoniaco elevada a la segunda potencia
entre la presión parcial del nitrógeno
elevada
vamos a ver en esta ecuación que ya está
balanceada el coeficiente es 1 entonces
elevada a la primera potencia por la
presión parcial del hidrógeno elevada a
la tercera potencia ok y como todas las
presiones son de una esfera tenemos 1.0
al cuadrado entre 1.0 a la 1 por 1.010
esto claro es igual a 1 así que en este
momento de la reacción q es igual a 1
vamos a sustituirlo en nuestra ecuación
y calculemos el valor de delta g
entonces si sustituimos q cuál es el
logaritmo natural de 1 bueno el
logaritmo natural de 1 es cero
entonces como esto es igual a cero esto
se cancela y nos queda que el cambio de
energía libre delta g
al cambio de energía libre estándar
delta g 0 que a esta temperatura es
igual a menos 33 kilos jules entonces el
cambio de energía libre delta g es igual
a menos 33.08 observen que obtuvimos un
valor negativo de delta g menos 33.0 eso
significa que nuestra reacción es
espontánea así que se favorece en los
productos obtendremos más amoniaco y
bueno ya dijimos que en este ejemplo
delta g es igual a delta g 0 y eso tiene
sentido porque delta g 0 es el cambio de
energía libre en condiciones estándar y
miren nosotros estamos precisamente en
condiciones estándar todo se encuentra a
una atmósfera finalmente si nosotros
queremos podemos escribir kilos jules a
mol de reacción porque un molde
nitrógeno se combina con tres moles de
hidrógeno para formar dos moles de
amoniaco entonces delta g el cambio de
energía libre para esta reacción es
igual a menos 33.08
ahora tenemos estas presiones parciales
digamos que todos los gases se
encuentran a 4.0 atmósferas entonces
cuando todos los gases tienen esas
presiones parciales cuál será la energía
libre en ese momento de la reacción a 25
grados celsius bueno nuevamente vamos a
calcular delta g nosotros sabemos que
delta g es igual a delta g 0 + rt por el
logaritmo natural de q
ok entonces primero vamos a calcular que
el cociente de reacción voy a escribir q
p en el ejemplo anterior ya vimos cómo
calcular q así que iré un poco rápido
aquí sería 4.0 a la segunda potencia
entonces 4.0 al cuadrado entre 4.0 a la
primera potencia 4.0
4.0 a la tercera potencia entonces 4.0
al cubo 4.0 al cuadrado es igual a 16
entre 4 por 4.0 al cubo es 64 usemos la
calculadora 16 entre 4 por 64 eso es
igual a cero punto cero 625 entonces en
este momento de la reacción el cociente
de reacción es igual a cero punto cero
625 vamos a sustituirlo en nuestra
ecuación y calculemos delta g del tajo
es igual a delta g 0 el cambio de
energía libre estándar y miren a 25
grados celsius delta g 0 es igual a
menos 33 kilos jules entonces menos 33.0
pero necesitamos convertirlos a jules
así que vamos a multiplicar
esto por 10 a la 3 más r la constante de
los gases que esté 8.314 jules / mol por
kelvin por eso necesitábamos que delta g
0 estuviera en yours formol después
tenemos la temperatura y en este caso la
temperatura de la reacción es de 25
grados celsius pero necesitamos
convertirlos a kelvin entonces 25 grados
celsius son 298 kelvin 298 kelvin así
los que elvin se cancelan y después
vamos a multiplicar por el logaritmo
natural de q
entonces logaritmo natural de cook que
es igual a cero punto cero 625 entonces
0.0 625 usemos la calculadora empecemos
con el logaritmo natural de
punto 0 625 tenemos logaritmo natural de
0.0 625 y este valor lo vamos a
multiplicar por 298 también
multiplicamos por 8.300 14 y vamos a
sumarle delta g 0 entonces más menos
33.0 por 10 a la 3 esto es igual a si lo
redondeamos y en kilo jules formol sería
menos 39.9 entonces delta g es igual a
menos 39.9 kilo yours por mol kilo jules
formol de reacción es más fácil pensar
en kilos por mol entonces para esta
reacción específica en donde un molde
nitrógeno se combina con tres moles de
hidrógeno para formar dos moles de
amoniaco delta g
igual a menos 39.9 kilo tools ahora
observen que delta g tiene un valor
negativo así que la reacción es
espontánea eso significa que se favorece
la formación de los productos pero ahora
pensemos en qué tan lejos nos
encontramos del equilibrio bueno nuestro
cociente de reacción que es 0.0 625 para
esta reacción a 25 grados celsius pero
la constante de equilibrio que la voy a
escribir como capte es igual a 6.1 por
10 a las 5 entonces miren el cociente de
reacción es 0.0 625 es mucho menor que
la constante de equilibrio entonces si q
es menor que acá podemos decir que hay
más reactivos y menos productos y como
delta g es negativa se favorece la
formación de los productos la reacción
es espontánea y bueno
como q no es igual acá estamos muy lejos
del equilibrio pero esta es una reacción
espontánea así que seguirá avanzando
para formar más productos ahora conforme
la reacción avanza qué pasa con q bueno
conforme la reacción avanza estamos
formando más productos así que el
numerador aumenta y además estamos
perdiendo reactivos así que los
reactivos disminuye entonces si aumenta
el numerador y disminuye el denominador
eso significa que conforme avanza la
reacción y se forman los productos q
aumenta pero conforme aumenta qué pasará
con delta g vamos a ver si q aumenta
cuál será el cambio de energía libre
vamos a suponer que q ahora es igual a
100 estamos en otro momento de la
reacción aquí que era igual a 0 punto 0
625 pero
ahora digamos que q es igual a sí que
pasará con delta g bueno vamos a
sustituir este valor en la ecuación y
veamos qué pasa
delta g es igual a menos 33.0 por 10 a
la 3 estos serían jules por mol pero no
voy a anotar las unidades para que sea
un poco más fácil este es el valor de
delta g ser entonces delta g 0 + 8.314
la constante de los gases por la
temperatura que aún nos encontramos a
298 kelvin aquí la única diferencia es
el valor de q que en este caso es igual
a 100 por el logaritmo natural de 100
aumentamos el valor de q y queremos
saber qué pasó con delta g usemos la
calculadora empecemos con el logaritmo
natural de 100 y esto lo vamos a
multiplicar por 298
después lo multiplicamos por 8.314
finalmente vamos a agregarle delta g 0
que es igual a menos 33.0 por 10 a la 3
- 33.0 por 10 a la 3 en kilo jules por
mol serían 21.6 kilo jules por mol
entonces delta g es igual a menos 21.6
kilo jules por mol de reacción entonces
al aumentar q pasamos de una delta g d -
39.9 a un delta g de menos 21.6 entonces
conforme la reacción avanza nos
acercamos a 0 y miren aún sigue siendo
una reacción espontánea porque tenemos
un valor negativo de delta g se favorece
la formación de los productos ahora
q sigue siendo menor acá q es igual a
100 pero que es igual a 6.1 por 10 a las
5 así que todavía la reacción se
favorece hacia los productos y bueno ya
dijimos que la reacción sigue siendo
espontánea pero ahora qué pasará al
equilibrio bueno sabemos que al
equilibrio del tajo debe ser igual a
cero entonces al equilibrio del traje es
igual a cero y q debe ser igual acá el
cociente de reacción es igual a la
constante de equilibrio vamos a
sustituir eso en nuestra ecuación y
comprobemos si es cierto delta g es
igual a delta g 0 menos 33.0 por 10 a la
3 más la constante de los gases que es
8.314
por la temperatura que sigue siendo de
298 pero ahora en lugar de escribir q
vamos a escribir acá vamos a sustituir
la constante de equilibrio que es de 6.1
por 10 a las 5 veamos qué pasa con delta
g usemos la calculadora tenemos
logaritmo natural de 6.1 por 10 a la 5
esto lo multiplicamos por 298 y después
lo multiplicamos por 8.314 esto es igual
a más 33 kilos jules 33 kilos jules o
33.0 por 10 a la 3
jules pero observe nosotros tenemos un
valor de delta g 0 de menos 33.0 por 10
a la 3 y todo esto nos dio un total de
mas 33.0 por 10 a la 3 así que delta g
es igual a 0 el cambio de energía libre
es igual a 0 cuando nos encontramos al
equilibrio es decir cuando q es igual a
k que al sustituirlo en la ecuación
pudimos comprobar que delta g es igual a
0 así que ya no se favorecen ni los
productos ni los reactivos porque nos
encontramos al equilibrio y eso
significa que las energías libres tanto
de los reactivos como de los productos
son iguales